hello everybody my name is markiplier
and uh I am an idiot oh my god I can't
believe how obvious this was I cannot
believe how obvious what what oh I can't
believe how obvious that was God I
remember because I looked over at the
Shelf I was like there's something
all those bookshelves while my hand is
over it on such an idiot Hey look keys I
picked up key can I pick up a more key
how much key can I have one whole key
yeah I got key office hey Qian move hard
with the key No No maybe worse one off
the lock doors okay so it's probably to
the locked door up stairs maybe let's go
see about that I'm halfway expecting
something to pop out just because I've
kind of had a bit of a doofus and have
not been progressing quickly in this
lets play but that's the way it is
sometime hey more content than you asked
for
alright let's see dink-dink where is my
wife a girlfriend I don't know wife - I
can't remember that lady that I sleep
with sometimes where is that lady why
I'd like to see her again
you don't kill her that'd be nice Oh
turn the box and
ducks and Oh a bathroom whoo interesting
very nice thanks nice I like it I've
never seen anything like this it's
awfully modern bathroom for a chandelier
but I'll pass ah okay I'm not in here
are those coming from below me oh so
it's not outside oh boy that was the
moose man not the other one that they
intro'd is everything behind those
paintings hope yep yep okay maybe they
took the laughs because it seemed as if
this guy's wife looks like the old wife
of that guy who's now Wow what's up what
you fell you really really tripped and
fell down the stairs
Oh Oh what what what Oh what what what
what's the deal okay running running out
[Applause]
okay all right
so I tripped and fell and got into a
nightmare okay unless something pushed
me of course that's always possible you
never know with these things
ah it was just a dream I don't think
that was a dream friend Oh
oh it got dark oh it got much darker all
the lights have gone out of it this is
not warm and inviting anymore nope ah
uh-huh
what are you gonna bust that out on me
that grunt oh you know wait running away
no one likes you
we've already established this oh wait
there's another rumor gonna bite
I don't you think he's gonna come
through that in the door
there is you oopsies
butchie's you didn't see anything buddy
you saw nothing nothing nothing
whatsoever
get out of here ins ok what's the deal I
didn't even hear a break okay he broke
you broke through while this guy's
taking forever to go why I probably
could've just run past him and try to
get the key to the other door in fact I
think I'm gonna do that yeah let's do
that
I'm not dig around Wow okay I've got a
dick around just for a little bit longer
and then chuck a barrel in his face I'm
ready come on come on yeah suck that
barrel down didn't know what to do
Oh blue riot Bassam didn't even get to
chase his wheel i'm hatsune me too bro
well yeah bust out of here I was already
in here before Oh someone reset all the
chairs Oh knives there we go
[Applause]
[Music]
so that's taken care of hopefully he
will be down there for a bit oh look an
arm oh yeah this guy cut off his own arm
and replaced it with a saw I think it's
more of a sword type object but saw
worst error is his arm and here's a
button I said oh hello oh wow sounds
like something happened on the second
floor what could it hit then oh I want
to see what happened like it uh dink
just cuz I don't ever use it ah what a
nice nice warm and inviting fire you
still out here
uh-huh yeah here didn't think so yeah
thank you
ah no I don't need that look at that
little light that I lit candle ahh bra
okay I think he's gone I don't know
what's up with that music that's freaky
like there's a constant repetitive
squeal huh oh no oh where to move man
come from
no thank you you can screw yourself I am
not going after him with a barrel I
don't care who's man I'm mousse man is
where I draw the line
grunts I can generally deal with Moosman
I mean Frigga frak
[Music]
is he just gonna be patrolling a while
okay I might have to oh nice
where are you where are you bring it on
bring it on
where are you all right that's what I
thought that's what I thought okay now
what change in man mmm the same
mysterious bleeding blood Devlin
saw earlier I'm actually doing good on
oil I've been very very conservative
about it
okay nothing in here I mean there was
this thing but I've already been in
there there's nothing more to be had
right right right right
Oh Marnie got that from that I got this
from this there's nothing else in here
okay good
I'll tell here thank you and get out of
here thank you
okay so anyhoo ah I found you I found it
[Music]
okay
secret cellar the only possible way for
Rachel to go he's in the secret sander
hmm
long load time interesting you know I've
been thinking about it a lot of people
have been um uh never mind never mind
that's such a secret that's gonna have
to wait until another day you're gonna
be on pins and needles while you're
waiting for me to try to say hi anybody
down here do you say no oh no Cadiz oil
love oil my girls so much
I like oil just about as much as I don't
like this what was that I heard
something what are you doing up there
get down from there
who puts barrels that high no no you sit
there oh wow
Oh get out yeah that's right back off oh
my goodness huh those of you was there
though then he was right behind me
get out of here oh man Oh golly
oh man it's gravy
I was redonkulous heck did that even
happen I don't know that's under the
stairs as peruse there's nothing under
the stairs OH
[Music]
all right why man I see something out
there okay I get I got stack what's that
lantern I already have a lantern
glycerol am I gonna make nitroglycerin
probably someone's been brushing up on
their science okay that was obvious to
make me look up so they want me to go up
there good thing I there's all these
barrels
let's bring to the lip hi babe yeah yeah
it's good thing I got all these Pro
barrel stacking skills no oh my hiding
place
he's is patrolling isn't he the dick
okay weird graphical blog going on there
not sure what it is either way I'm gonna
go away what are you doing I'm gonna
keep building you just aa barrel in
front of my face it works kind of you
didn't hear anything buddy you heard
nothing
go screw yourself go screw yourself
[Music]
I think I only need like three to get up
there let's just get up here and then
I'll go on my merry way think Oh
so pro okay what's up here gather way
get get cos get me okay
nope nope nothing I need nothing I need
I need nothing nothing nothing no wasted
my time on a red hair you you dropped a
barrel of course I'm gonna try to get up
here alright that was disappointing
that's all that time I got for this
episode thank you all so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next part
barbar okay bye bye